The Coronavirus outbreak hit people across the world,
claiming too many lives.
It infected the very roots of our economy
and raised many questions
about our health care systems.
In this first episode of "What's Left?"
we take a closer look at the spread
of the crisis to the economy.
I hope that we will learn some lessons.
In 2008, we had a major crisis.
Everyone said: "we're going to change everything,
we're going to change everything".
We clearly see that nothing has changed.
This crisis might just be the opportunity
to rethink Europe's current economic model.
And here's how.
As countries start deconfining one after the other,
economic figures are out and they're not reassuring.
The global freeze of the economy
- a first in modern history -
is set to cause the Eurozone to contract by 7.5% this year,
the worst recession since the Great Depression.
As long as we don't have a remedy, a vaccine,
this sword of Damocles hangs over our heads.
It generates uncertainty in margins that we have never seen.
So now the question is, what will happen after confinement?
The jobs of up to 59 million people in Europe are at risk;
that's almost the entire population of France.
Beyond the numbers, we are talking
about the livelihoods of citizens,
their incomes and their plans for the future
that were put in question overnight.
There are have been legislative and budgetary actions
by member states since the beginning of the crisis.
However, these measures will unevenly affect member states
due to the different spread of the virus,
but also due to the different structures
of the economies of those states.
It took a month of confinement before EU leaders
finally took action as one united block.
A common "bazooka" package amounting
to €540 billion,
was agreed on in April to protect workers,
businesses
and countries.
This is a European crisis, not that of one single State.
and it must be addressed as such.
Therefore, the costs have to be shared.
In the longer term, all EU countries will need cash
to face the economic consequences of the crisis,
in other words finance a massive recovery plan.
If we take a look at history,
we may find some clues to figure out what to do next.
In the 1930s, to pull his country out of the Depression,
Roosevelt decided to take radical measures.
He tripled the federal budget in a few years,
created new resources,
putting in place a federal tax on profits
and on the richest.
The first year it didn't work out.
Roosevelt emitted bonds for a few years
and with a massive stimulus package
his tax plan paid off.
For today's Progressives
this precedent in history could give us a way out.
One tool governments have in their toolbox
to finance their actions,
in addition to taxation, is debt.
In normal times,
all European countries can issue bonds
to borrow money on the financial markets.
But at some point those countries
will have to reimburse the money.
If financial markets trust your country,
they will lend money easily,
at low interest rates.
The first thing was to say:
"there are countries that are going
to be more affected than others
by this health crisis."
So there are countries
that will have more public debt than others.
But for other countries that don't look quite as stable,
interest rates can rise.
Financial markets can say:
"Ah, but you are less trusted!
So we're going to ask you for interest rates at 2% or 3%.
This has a tremendous impact on a country's ability
to restore its economic strength.
What might seem like a pretty insignificant
rise in interest rates
can quite quickly turn into billions
of Euros to be paid back.
When we anticipate that one country
will be more affected than another,
can we arbitrate its public debt against
that of a country that would be less affected?
If this arbitration mechanism occurs,
we have a sort of hellish circle
which leads to penalising the most affected countries.
It's a totally unfair mechanism.
It is a reverse solidarity. An anti solidarity.
In order to avoid this competition between states
and make sure we have a truly solidarity-based recovery,
Progressives in the European Parliament
put the idea of issuing
corona bonds at a European level on the table.
In other words, a common European debt.
Each country would keep its debt capacity,
but Europe, as such, would also
have the capacity to generate debt.
The financial markets would take it as
the signature of the best of them.
Some people call it "corona bonds",
because it's somehow linked to the coronavirus crisis
but it would not only concern the health aspect.
It would also help to finance the recovery plan.
If the EU jointly borrows money on the financial markets,
it also needs to be able to jointly
pay back money borrowed.
The Progressives are pushing to create new own resources
for the EU budget to create independent
revenue for the EU.
Asking for a fee on un-recycled plastics,
drawing resources from the European Emissions Trade System,
raising income taxes on big corporates,
creating a digital services tax,
putting in place a tax on financial transactions,
while making sure the revenues from tax avoidance
and tax evasion
go where the money is needed.
A few weeks into confinement,
people woke up to a world where the air was clean
and where traffic wasn't a nuisance anymore.
Spectacular drops in CO2 emissions were observed.
But this doesn't give us the bigger picture.
In the last year,
C02 emissions have risen more rapidly than in the 60s and 70s,
from 0,8 units to 2,8 per year.
Temperatures continue to rise everywhere,
and with it our need to deal with the situation.
We just lived the horror
but at least there was tap water.
Imagine if we do nothing about the climate!
Can you imagine the horror if the tap water
runs out in our houses or hospitals?
Did we understand the beauty of life
and the fragility of life?
Isn’t it high time that we put finance
at the service of life?
So how do we do it?
How do we protect citizen's jobs and livelihoods
while addressing the biggest challenge
humanity has probably ever had to face?
For the Socialists and Democrats, the path is clear,
it’s called the Green New Deal,
with a just transition at its heart,
to ensure that no one is left behind
when we re-build our economies and our societies
on a sustainable basis.
As general rapporteur for the budget,
I am fighting to have a very ambitious budget,
a recovery and transformation budget
to be able to create 5 million jobs.
If we want to win the climate battle,
all houses, schools, retirement homes,
universities must be isolated.
Public transport must be developed.
We have to change our agricultural model.
To do that, we need between €300 and
€500 billion each year.
In the end, progressive ideas caught
the Commission’s ear
and by the end of May it proposed
a comprehensive recovery plan:
€750 billion to support the bloc's economies.
These investments would come on top
of an existing€1.1 trillion wide budgetary plan.
The hardest hit sectors in the most affected regions
must be provided with a life-line
to ensure they don't have to fire workers
or close-down before recovery kicks in.
The S&D Group will continue putting pressure
on EU leaders so that Europe can live up to its ambitions.
Let's be honest about it,
the problem is not to put more money on the table.
The issue here is getting Europe to move forward.
President Von Der Leyen,
as you can see, in this Parliament,
you have an institution that is always ready to work
for the good of our citizens.
Now, it's up to you to convince our friends in the EU Council.
We owe it to future generations.
With the Coronavirus crisis,
we've all been left in a state of shock.
First and foremost was protecting people's health,
supporting the most vulnerable in society,
and ensuring that workers will have
a job to return to after the end of the outbreak.
But then, we also woke up to a new world of possibilities,
working from home, experimenting new forms of solidarity.
And when the clapping stops and when, bit-by-bit,
that sense of normality comes back into our lives,
what will we do?
Will we go back to our old ways,
or will we embrace real change?
In this crisis,
the Progressives will have fought and pushed for a real change,
refusing to sit on the sidewalk of history while watching workers,
businesses and our planet go bust.
Now, it is time to be bold and innovative
and build a better future for all.
Stay tuned for a next episode of "What's Left?"
where we will explore in more depth
how tomorrow's world could look like.